how are you Doug I'm doing well my man
thanks for having me on
you are my pleasure are you kidding me
let's let's talk about this Seattle
Seahawks season before we get to the
televisions what is the mindset here
what is the mindset of this team
entering a big huge game if not the
biggest marquee afternoon game of week 1
against the Green Bay Packers Doug yeah
this entire offseason we kind of just
wanted to get back to basics of who we
are as the Seattle Seahawks and
basically that comes down to just having
fun you know if we have fun that we know
that we're gonna execute at a high level
I'm gonna go there and play with passion
and tenacity and aggressiveness but it
comes down to us having fun and that's
really what we're trying to do we just
want to have fun with our teammates out
there playing sports we love well it's
interesting that that's the word you use
Doug I would say a lot of the reports
and a lot of the articles that are
written is that this team yes likes to
have fun but there always has to have
some sort of undercurrent of controversy
that keeps you guys I guess energized is
that a a valid evaluation of your locker
room Doug I don't know that that we need
it we necessarily need it I just think
that you know for any human being right
when your back against the wall you have
adversity you know you're either gonna
come out of it better or you cannot
allow that adversity to weigh you down
and we have elite competitors in our
locker room you know I'm not gonna say
we've athletes obviously everybody in
the NFL is an elite athlete there's a
lot of elite athletes that aren't in the
NFL but for elite competitors you know
we when we face adversity when we have
those challenges we look forward to them
and more times than not we're going to
come out on top and I think that's
that's basically what you're saying is
that you know when we have our adversity
we thrive in those conditions so that
it's no different for any other human
being especially for these elite
competitors and we enjoy that so if you
had to choose an adjective to describe
the relationship between the offensive
and defensive units of this team what
would that adjective be Doug Baldwin I
don't know if I could use one attitude
okay
to describe that I would have to say
that it the term that comes in mind is
iron sharpens iron
you know we're and sometimes it's not
always pretty when you when one when
you're sharpening something sometimes
you know sparks fly and you have that uh
that are that friction but that's that's
the important aspect that that's that's
why you know you're sharpening that tool
and so that I think that's that's the
perfect analogy that I can use to
represent our relationship now in terms
of Sherman with uh with your quarterback
and Russell Wilson are you would you say
you're a buffer that you you know you
were Stanford guy and Sherman's a
Stanford guy and yura and obviously a
Russell Wilson guy being on that offense
would that be another valid assessment
of your role no I know I know the
perception is that Russell and Sherman
had some major difference but it's not
true I mean again it goes back to the
analogy of ironing iron sharpening iron
you know these these guys to early
competitors and you know they they don't
always see eye to eye and that's good
because if they did then you know
where's the growth in that we need that
conflict at times and you know it's not
a it's not a divisive or destructive
conflict because those guys are both
very mature and very intelligent and
they can utilize strengthening each
other for the better of each other and
so no I don't need to be a buffer
because those guys yeah they have it
under control
Seahawks wide receiver Doug Baldwin
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
what what were your thoughts on Jermaine
Kearse now being with the Jets you do
get a very supremely talented guy on the
defensive line and children Richardson
but somebody from your wide receiver
core and wide receiver room is now
wearing different green on the outset of
the season Doug what are your thoughts
there yeah this time of the season where
after the last P season game I should
say it's probably one of the most
difficult times emotionally for football
players because you know like you said
you lose P words you become
be close to guys who are vying for an
opportunity on teams don't get to
somebody to stay you know regardless of
the effort that they give those
difficult convoys and obviously losing
probably one of my me one of my best
friends on the team who I've grown with
for the past six years it was tough it
was definitely an emotional hit and a
surprise but I'm an optimistic person
and I look at his opportunity over there
was the Jets to get to showcase his
talents with with a pretty good
quarterback you know on a team that's
that's that's trying to figure it out so
and obviously like you said we did get a
great teammate and in return and I've
already seen the type of person he is
and the type of playing for the befall
defense so you know I do believe that
it's a win-win for both sides even
though it is said and see my best
friends oh yeah and it's interesting and
I'd love to just stay on this topic a
little bit Doug about the cuts right the
turk visiting on of all weekends by the
way a weekend named Labor Day weekend
it's really ironic in that way that you
know you got guys who were hopes and
dreams dashed and now they're on either
unemployment or trying to figure out
what their next gig is gonna be and I'm
wondering if if you wear the the way you
came into this league every snap every
play that's the way that you make sure
that you stay at an elite level Doug I'd
love to get your mindset on all that
yeah my mom mentality has never been
about trying to I guess when is the best
way I can describe it it's not about
specifically just wanting I love to
compete all right I just I just love to
be counted out you know and in the
negativity to believe that I'm not gonna
make it and that's that's taken we'd be
in my entire life in the football world
is I had to prove somebody wrong but not
only prove it somebody wrong but I've
also had to prove myself right because
as a human I do have my internal doubts
about myself as well so that's always
been my mentality and yeah come
into the NFL being undrafted again had
to prove others wrong of course but also
prove myself right that I am capable of
playing and this in this league and then
once I got here realizing ok does what
can you do and this initially can you be
an elite player and so again proving
others others wrong but also proving
myself right so that's the mentality
that I have every time I step on that
football field is that I had an
opportunity again to prove myself right
to to utilize the blessings of God given
me and not take them for granted and
showcase them on on a platform now so
that's my mentality every time I stepped
on the ball and you also when you step
off the football field understand that
there's a platform for you as well and
last we spoke on this show Doug I think
the Attorney General of the state of
Washington tweeted at University let's
talk about what's on your mind about
policing about community relations and
I'm wondering where that stands with you
Doug in the rest of your teammates right
now yeah so right now obviously you know
Michael Bennett is is continuously
continuing the conversation outside of
the organization but I'm working
diligently right now internally so to
make our organization a model for the
rest of the NFL especially sports teams
you know we're doing a lot of things
internally I don't want to speak on it
right now okay cuz you know I wanna I
want to generate more of a story behind
it but we're doing a lot of work you
know we're we're trying to educate
ourselves in the grand picture of
everything and and trying to make a
difference but obviously like I said
before on your show is that we have to
learn as much as you can first before we
can we can do that so then if let's go a
little bit macro then instead of getting
into the nitty-gritty details what do
you mean about being a template for
other teams and for other teams in
sports what do you mean by that
well I think you know obviously there's
there's been this conversation that was
started last year year to have to go but
now we want to further that you know
what do we do with this conversation
first and foremost we have to get on the
same pages is how do we discuss this and
what's the proper language you know in
and that's important if we're gonna have
the conversation we all need to utilize
the same the same language so that's
that's why I'm starting now is we're
gonna get on the same page about this
language about what it means you know
the different best admissions and again
I don't want to get too much into it but
what it means to have this conversation
and then that way everybody's on the
same page and then we can discuss more
in depth and more and through emotion
and experiences of what life really
means to different people and different
perspectives and then hopefully that
injects some empathy and to the people
that that we're going to be working with
in our organization to help further this
conversation and then the call to action
is basically to have this conversation
outside of the facility with their
family members with their friends and
then obviously with their children so
that this this type of mentality this
type of thought process of being willing
to accept others even when they're
different from you will manifest itself
forth for future generations couple more
minutes with Doug bald one of the
Seattle Seahawks here on the Rich Eisen
show what are you doing with Visio the
big screens for big plays what's this
all I'm helping them support this
program they got going on so this year
every time a play of forty yards and
more ends with a touchdown video we'll
be giving away a 50-inch in series smart
cast this play this real simple anyone
can go and sign up and enter for a
chance to win all you got to do is go to
Vizio comm splat sports last big plays
it's real simple Vizio dot-com slash big
plays and then last last we heard from
Sherman he wrote he wrote this piece for
the players Tribune about his biggest
challenge wasn't anything in the locker
room was baby proofing his house can you
give us an update on that Doug any
update on that yeah he's doing really
well said
some adjustments as a new father but
he's doing extremely well with that
proof that you can be a shutdown corner
in the NFL but you can't shut down those
little ones can you target you know when
it comes down no you know you can't it's
a difficult task for sure okay and touts
Tyler Lockett doing before I let you go
can you give me something on him at all
yeah you do really well you know he's
definitely ahead of schedule and uh
always smiling so we can't wait to see
him out there you okay you keeping an
eye on Oakland to see how beast mode is
doing at all of course keep an eye on
Oakland keeping an eye on the Jets keep
an eye on the Browns you know I got a
lot of friends in the league right now
so okay just enjoying that success well
Doug I'm enjoying your success always
love having you on please do when you
want to put more meat on the bones about
what you're doing internally please call
back I'd love to I'd love to hear about
it I will do appreciate that Rick you
got it good luck this season that's Doug
Baldwin at Doug Baldwin jr. jr. on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy